[Music]
in newts for charity news Oh Daniel
Horace a model of selling nude photos
for Australian wildfire donations got
her Instagram account shut down over
turkey about this yeah well how about
the fires
well they're raising money you can't
show your only fans account
she raised something like sixty thousand
dollars or something like that million
grew a million that's the made it a
million oh [__] selling nudes
oh my god so where's this a topless
[__] Oh her she's someone that
usually is in nude so that's what's that
much more vows you recently started
doing the nude thing but she's a model
oh she added new term portfolio recently
diversify yeah should diversify so [__]
for koalas Kailen Kailen ward she's 20
years old from here in California and so
she ended up tweeting oh actually this
is what she looks like she's 2020 yeah
she doesn't a Golder who's too young
dirty something there are hookers and
absurd ad that look like that well you
can see her nipple in that you can't
fully good I mean dude it's right there
it's like [__] wicked I knew I was
looking at the bikini looking at her
yeah you miss the [__] I think that's a
guy see immediate eases so I was looking
at her shoulder that's her nipple inside
of her areola like that our areola yeah
yeah that's the true Larry areola slip
okay it's a little patreon preview yeah
here's another photo and so yeah she
tweeted this out Jesus yeah I saw that
I'm sending nudes to every person who
donates at least $10 to any one of these
fundraisers for the wildfires in
Australia every $10 you donate equals
one nude picture from me to your diem
you must send me confirmation that you
donated please retweet hashtag Australia
on fire
hashtag Australia fires what a pain yeah
all that money to Australia so she's not
receiving any money she wants people to
donate - donate to this list Oh st.
yeah that's so yeah she listed all of
UT's going to heaven for sure right and
and so she fought for news not if not if
my god says anything about what she
should so she ended up tweeting later
she got shut down that sucks it does
suck she's doing a great thing this is
posted January 3rd three days later she
tweeted out would you believe me if I
told you we raised an estimated 1
million dollars that's amazing yeah I
don't know dude was bend over and take a
photo how good do you girls feel right
now no I I'm so into it cuz you has a
new [__] wah wah I'll show you berry
donated donated yeah well my wife
donated thank you
what did you do I donated I'd like put
it on my store my wife huh you [__] bags
that was from our joint account thank
you also I did do that alright so she
ended up getting it so she was saying
that she had to enlist the help of three
people because she couldn't go through
all the DMS herself so she found taint
doubles no to go through her go through
it it's embarrassing
all the people there to show her buggy
interns to help her send nudes pretty
much because she promised a nude for
every $10 there were some people yeah
there's some people that were donating
so she said one person donated $5,000 in
at least 10 people donated why hundred a
hundred thousand dm's at least yeah a
lot of photos how do you know the same
photo so she went up she sure likes open
her legs and cover half of it so it's
like one and then and then open up the
other flap and they're not some other
people
if she had flaps she wouldn't get $10
she it more or less
she's rudderless what rudderless what is
that that thing is tight it has nothing
to do with being tighter vagina there's
that that are pretty tight yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying
big curtains what is that like the the
runners that's what I'm saying this is
what it was the tightness there's nobody
to do it Taylor that's the rudders that
he's talking about Suzanne I'm talking
about because I've seen the crusty
you're talking about the vulva yeah and
whether the vulva is flappy or not
flapping there isn't a flappy bird or is
bottom at it sounds the key I think you
know Gonzalez
I've seen some motors ball rudders yeah
you mean he's breaking thank you Kelly
we're broken it's tricky deeper though
saw some ping-pong paddles you have his
back boyfriend Oh always Wow anyway so
always has wings
that's cause some have rudders yeah and
some don't have wings right but it has
nothing to do with the efficiency huh no
but I know one that doesn't have wings
what the [__] is going on in this truck
and head weight again because he did so
much to do not get lead he did a lot my
back too and that winking is gonna help
him get let that [__] just because
she's translator doesn't mean she has
your back okay sorry sorry apologies I
mean you think that you want no
translating the way he's trying to do
all right so some of you might be
wondering why does Palin who care so
much about these fires in Australia was
she's from 500,000 wild animals died so
for her there's a lot of people that
care that meanie
yeah but there's a lot
for sure nothing that wouldn't care I'm
just saying right her specific
500-million because I'm trying to get to
the reason as to why she cares so she
said that's reading reports about the
wildfires like it really made her want
to go into action because she has lived
through the 2018 car fire in
California's Shasta County that killed
at least six people and destroyed more
than 1,000 homes and the car fire
threatened her family's home forcing
them to take refuge on a houseboat and
but luckily her family's home was saved
but she said that trips to Chico were
her then fiance's daughter lived to go
pick her up put her in proximity to the
campfire which turned out to be
california's deadliest and most
destructive fire in our history not so
because lived a lot of life for a
twenty-year-old do you no wonder she
sold nets to get her own house back true
now that she knows oh yeah so um so then
she's saying like just see she said we
were driving the Chico to pick up my
ex's daughter and the skies were purple
and yellow and orange and looked
apocalyptan what elliptic you could see
and smell the ash in the air over on
Lake Shasta everything was smoky a month
later this the sky was still great so
for her she felt like a very personal
connection to that she wanted to do
something to help and that's the reason
why she came up with this and she
doesn't even have to answer [__] even
people want to do something and she did
one of those things that were like you
can't you could tell that she's not
gonna pocket the money or whatever it's
legit for charity because all you got to
do is show receipt yeah you're going to
the links that you owe that doesn't even
know they're like oh you're doing this
well I did [__] donate so then
they'll find the old receipt and they'd
get some [__] pictures for it nobody's
to be like why are you doing me for most
really like I could get a pissy pic
right now yeah like who the [__] is
hating and saying you're not even it was
a from Estrella why do you care so much
why are you doing I'm not saying that
we're haters I'm just giving you a
reason as to why we thought that there
were haters I'm not saying that I drew
Instagram hater for sure it hurt
don't but I'm not verifying that I think
the the Instagram though Instagram did
get shut down because they're saying
like this was violated the the policies
I mean some flat grass right yeah no no
so my facebook spokesperson said that
her account was disabled for violating
their policies offering nude images is
not allowed on Instagram oh maybe she
went [__] didn't open the floodgates so
she she had two accounts they both got
shut down and a whole bunch of fakes
rose up even one even got up to 20,000
followers and so she they had to post on
Twitter like this is this is a fake take
it down but they re posting like her
photos on to these accounts that are
getting a lot of followers but she was
like they're not taking down the face
Instagram is not taking down the face
but the owners yeah yeah so that's kind
of weird but a lot of them if they're
Rhys repassing around her news they're
kind of interning for her because we've
all are sending their receipts and she's
there like they're giving the pictures
true she doesn't do any more work that's
I think how much money do the people
that actually have nudes me oh yeah know
enough to make a living it's a killer
killer babies make millions well so now
there's other there's other girls
jumping in on this on the same I guess
now it's a trend um and so I read like
Riley Reid who's a porn actor she
tweeted I saw my first hand how horrid
the hashtag Australia but fires are
people and animals are dying and losing
their homes please spread awareness and
donate email me proof of donation I'll
send you personal photos and or videos
and she put the link I can give him for
free son I get it but I don't know guys
have a thing for like all this personal
it's like Oh for me yeah thanks
cuz I yeah and is it with a marker on
her belly that says my name yeah didn't
you can kind of see the last that was
like
her belly was a whiteboard she had the
[__] dry eraser and go back and
nobody do want to mention though like it
is pretty crazy what's happening with
Australia fire is at least 24 people
have died and more than 200 fires have
been burning around this and they cut
they cut arsonists right yeah the cars
oh it was like maybe not 80 years I
don't know was it a tanning thing that
this is an unprecedented crisis yeah I
was looking at graphs of the height of
fires and like our fires were like so
tiny compared to the height of their
fires she's insane we're given million
dollars to hoping oh that's cool it's
yesterday yeah yeah so is Margot Robbie
and I think she donated what was the
motive for the arsonist
oh yeah and then um I just I have this
article pulled up here about that the
fact that Australia will have snipers
and helicopters to shoot thousands of
camels to conserve water
camels yeah whatuh camels do yeah does
it drink too much water and drinking too
much water and it's and they needed to
put the fires off why don't they just
like move um how much water can they
possibly dream we should send em some
use bottled water so would be a whole
lot of water for a long period of time
yeah I don't know but they're saying
that work in order to conserve resources
they need to do this so there's a hurt
against Rayo yes so they're saying that
snipers will take two helicopters to
hunt 4,000 and 5,000 camels Oh what are
they doing in Australia cam imagine
being a real camel fan your sniper over
there oh that's a love camels are
[__] I don't know cabals live in
Australia yes there's a cinema cloud and
just rain on the entire country at once
cuz it's somewhere out there right now
dude yeah them up with one don't they
say that we couldn't yeah they true we
gave control weather and stuff yeah damn
it is summer
environmental officials maybe this is -
maybe there are sins are they working
for harp - to show like why we need as a
public that us to control the weather so
that she like this cuz it doesn't happen
and so then they can come in and do you
think I'm not doing it on my path then
I've been I'm a we want to get we want
in any riffraff in a conspiracy corner
not [__] I want to be in you go through
our initiation what is it
I can't tell you unless you're serious
yeah it's we'll take off camera
[Music]